[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o court
então imaginem que viva em um país sem
luz
imaginem que à noite as únicas luzes que
existem são as luzes dos faróis dos
carros são as luzes das lanternas das
pessoas que passeiam pelas ruas
imaginem que a terra neste país e que a
única luz nesse país à noite é o
aeroporto e quando o último passageiro
sai tudo escurece
imaginem que os nossos filhos estudam e
vivem num país em que tem provado casa o
seu banco porque a escola não tem bugs 4
outra inclui vários usaram uma um saco
plástico nós vemos nos supermercados
aqui durante todo o ano letivo para
carregar o seu material escolar para a
escola e este país chamas guiné bissau e
agora perguntam e como é que uma pessoa
vai passar a parar
é isso aí vai parar à guiné bissau então
vamos retroceder um pouco vamos ter ao
ano de 2011 foi um ano em que eu
trabalhei numa escola que tinha um
acordo de cooperação com o instituto
camões e os filhos na escola alunos de
palop u$1 moçambique a santo mé cabo
verde guiné bissau e foi por estes
alunos por lá tipo testemunhos na
primeira pessoa daqui o que eles viveram
experience haram durante a sua infância
durante o seu período escolar todas
essas coisas que nós vemos e conhecemos
os vídeos do youtube ou por plantar
notícias na televisão mas foi por euros
que sim então vamos porque não há lugar
em todos os conceitos todas aquelas
disciplinas que estudam na escola porém
tudo que eu sou pendem nos aplicar tudo
isso em projetos que sirvam bem maior o
bem comum e que possam facto melhorar a
vida de outras pessoas
e foi assim que nasceu o projeto
tabancas o ar estava em campo também que
a ideia entre o ora o dia
fio simples não tinha nawa o desafio foi
lançado aos alunos foi então como é que
nós encontramos soluções para estes
problemas estão aqui elencados nas
soluções possam vir a ser feitas como
atrás de nós encontramos em qualquer
parte do mundo e que possam vir a ser
replicadas por pessoas que não têm
qualquer instrução ou que têm pouca
instrução em outros países
não era um desafio muito sinte e pra
isso pra nós conseguimos também montar
todo este projecto
tivemos que tentar encontrar parceiros
todos conhecemos as escolas todos
sabemos que os orçamentos das escolas
não são muito grandes então tivemos que
terá portas
vamos então bater à porta e tentar
encontrar os parceiros que nos pudessem
oculta' alguns materiais e pudéssemos
fato levar a cabo este projecto
ora quanto aqui um episódio do do ex
parceiro estava um dia à noite haverá um
programa de televisão que começa por ess
é esse programa de televisão estava uma
empresa a apresentar um produto que eu
achei que era er isto era mesmo isso que
nós precisamos para conseguirmos levar
para conseguirmos alavancar este projeto
e eu pensei ok esta empresa fica em
silicon valley
do outro lado do atlântico eu posso
mandar um e mail pra lá mas dos pra em
menos tempo até obter uma resposta
o fato não diz quinto mandei um e-mail e
duas horas depois recebi resposta várias
reuniões para skype depois recebemos em
portugal o tratamento material que nós
precisávamos para podermos fazer parte
desse projeto em áfrica e por isso não
estudarem conseguirem fazer e manuais
fazer protótipos de estarem chegou a
altura então levarmos este projecto e
implementarmos efetivamente no tempo
porque isso que é importante
é importante que os alunos nas escolas
trabalhem em projetos mas estes
projectos que não fiquem nas gavetas
é preciso trazer o carro para fora é
preciso mostrar aos alunos que esses
projetos funcionam com seu trabalho e
vale
então foi assim que fui para a guiné
bissau eis aí a senhora é um país onde
não tem qualquer recolha de subsídios
o android nós vemos o lixo amontoado nas
ruas de bissau
um é como é que este caso com muitos
problemas a nível de saúde público e que
deu depois origem a um projeto que está
atualmente em curso numa das escolas
portuguesas estarão letivo
temos um país quando temos ainda as
pessoas a confeccionar refeições de
forma tradicional numa fogueira ou no
forno melhorava como é o caso daqui que
tem também não entanto vários problemas
podemos utilizar menor lá - considerado
lenha no entanto são fórum das crianças
conseguem chegar risquei mão e um de
maior flor geus das crianças da guiné
bissau é precisamente às queimaduras não
há como tratar estas queimaduras são
queimaduras que muitas vezes são
tratados de uma forma muito tradicional
mas que deixa marcas para toda a vida e
este seu tamanho origem a um projeto já
implementado e depois temos um país onde
há água potável é um luxo
se eu fiz essa aqui existe vamos
perguntar quantas torneiras você está aí
nas nossas casas nossos começam a pensar
quantas casas lá enquanto na cozinha se
eu tenho um pacto está em alguma coisa
numa varanda mas fato 345 como agregado
familiar pelo menos duas três quatro
pessoas é que estamos a falar num poço
da água que não é potável como uma
torneira por uma comunidade 400 pessoas
foi esta realidade que encontrei quando
cheguei a guiné bissau mas também
encontrei pessoas que também encontraram
soluções para muitos problemas por
exemplo um destes problemas e eu lembro
que estou a falar de um país onde 70% a
posição não também dá acesso à
eletricidade então temos aqui pessoas
que foram empreendedoras
então neste caso esta pessoa que fez
investiu num no gerador e investiu
uma antena é captar o sinal dos ilegal e
transmitir em sua casa os jogos de
futebol e cobrava entrala hora eu posso
dizer que eu fui assistir a um jogo de
futebol diz num desses estão aqui mas eu
não vou dizer qual o clube que é pra não
ficar aqui em mais sete unidades
como também existe por exemplo a mesma
situação enquanto a novela num visor
onde um lado não estavam as pessoas a
ver a telenovela e do outro lado as
pessoas ouvir porque porque não tiveram
dinheiro para pagar todo o dia 30 eu só
ouvia muito a novela não estava a ver a
imagem é é onde encontramos também de
frentes transporte escolar daqueles que
nós temos cá em portugal uma situação
desta central tenha preço certeza eu
perguntei na altura a pessoa que
conduzir estas crianças porque para
evitar que as crianças vão a pé
tanto tempo e tantos quilômetros para a
escola os pais congregam as pessoas num
só local e depois são levados para a
escola e esta pessoa e edgar nesta
cozinha 27 crianças
luís e um feliz e depois também temos o
transporte que nós vamos passar é nós
fazemos questão do não vamos trabalhar
nesse dados
vamos sim daquelas aldeias que pararam
no tempo que não tem saneamento que não
tem luz quando ninguém chega ou não vêem
um médico um enfermeiro durante 23 anos
nós fazemos questão de trabalhar e
implementar os projetos dos alunos
nestas aldeias porque entendemos que é
ali que elas vão fazer a diferença e por
isso nem que significa termos que fazer
40 minutos dentro de um barco metago no
rio com o grupo deus teve que ser
ou então teremos ficaram os colocava
outro lado numa luna para chegar ou mal
ideia e temos que pedir um trator
emprestado em fazer 14 quilômetros em
duas horas
também acontecer depois chegamos ao
daiichi e trabalhar normal daí não é
assim qualquer maneira nós temos quer o
mal daí pedir autorização ao
chego para trabalhar universal é um país
muito pequeno tem um milhão e meio de
habitantes mas é um país que tem 37
etnias distintas cada uma com a sua
cultura e suas tradições e por exemplo
uma das questões que distancia distinga
os régulos das diferentes etnias é
precisamente as suas vestes neste caso
estávamos em um funk
nesta ao daea e o recuo vestia vermelho
se fossemos para aldeia seguinte
provavelmente já vestia branco ou retire
azul duas particularidades aqui
a primeira é que o rego carrega sempre
um banquinho porque de acordo com a sua
crença orrego não sentem qualquer lado e
carrega sempre o seu bairro para a
consciência tem lançado poder sentar e
depois a segunda particularidade é que
nesta fotografia e oferecer uma valorosa
tirar uma fotografia e os sempre uma
paródia ao rego é um local
o pam país anda fora das cidades é
possível não tem diz países e como não
tem espelhos não sabem com o qual é sua
aparência só olhando mesmo para o o o
flex unagui que consegue ver por isso
levar uma paulada tirar uma fotografia
oferecer essa fotografia é toda aquelas
pessoas que connosco vão trabalhando no
terreno e não só uma moda é nossa com
que ficam e ao movimento memória também
deus próprio que ficam para a vida deles
e então chegamos aonde vamos da formação
porque ótica aqui é sim ensinar a fazer
nós não vemos nada foi de portugal
nós levamos os manuais cuscuz alunos
fizeram vários protótipos vamos mostrar
e damos formação aos professores os
professores na guiné bissau são a coreia
profissão mais respeitado e por isso
sabemos que é um som bom veículo de
informação e sabemos que a formação vai
ser propagada por gestantes aldeias por
isso fazemos questão da primeira
formação aos professores
ora é chegamos pra dar a formação sobre
o ator luz já vão ver o que é que é
é e quando chegamos que seremos o grupo
está motivado temos aqui cerca de 20
pessoas já estavam na sala à vossa
espera ele estão sedo estão aqui está o
e e também que vai vendo aquela alda e
daquela idéia daquela idéia e disse já
estão cá já alguns tinham caminhava 456
horas durante a noite para estar ali
àquela hora nossa espera
e isso fez ver que são ávidos para
aprender e fez ver também que nós
tínhamos ali uma responsabilidade muito
grande
fomos então dono então a formação e
passamos a parte prática que é uma gota
de luxo uma gota luz é uma coisa tão
simples quanto uma garrafa d'água
aplicando um conceito da física ou
química refração da luz torna numa
lâmpada sular tão simples quanto isto
não foi possível trazer nenhuma comigo
no avião porque acharam que era uma arma
potencialmente perigosa mas gastar
fotografia para mostrar como ela então
passamos a prata que fomos então colocar
a primeira lâmpada solar na casa de um
dos professores que ofereceu sua casa
como local para a prática
ora é primeiras quebras a casa e esta
mostra foi atirada ao meio dia como
vemos isto é uma casa da guiné bissau
durante o dia
são casas extremamente escuras no seu
interior são escuras porque porque não
há qualquer tipo de abertura para não
entrar calor então constrói nas
completamente às escuras e sem aberturas
e depois da publicação de uma lâmpada
solar podemos ver efetivamente como é
que a casa é por dentro é só para terem
uma noção ânimos
é é a intensidade da energia e ter cerca
de 40 a 50 watts de energia no pico do
calor que é mais do que uma lâmpada
normal que nós temos nas nossas casas
hora
quantos um episódio precisamente desta
lâmpada solar quando pusemos a lâmpada
assim era da casa dona da casa mãe daqui
é o professor com os gritos
completamente e nós estamos observando
um xaile na altura se calhar o show que
estragamos o telhado
se calhar acha que vai entrar água
estamos a tentar explicar não estava em
mudar nos preocupe o primeiro
chamaram-nos do feiticeiro e atenção
talvez ser chamado fez em áfrica não é
uma coisa boa
depois o senhor só dizia eu finalmente
posso fechar a porta da minha casa
foi uma coisa que não entendi a primeira
vez ela dizia e o finalmente posso
deixar a porta da minha casa porque
porque na época das chuvas
mantinha a porta aberta para poder
entrar alguns poucos quero ver lá dentro
mas tudo o que era lixo entrava por
dentro de casa à procura de um local
seco e por isso presta pessoa poder
fechar a porta de casa já era uma
mudança muito grande e não explicavam
para europeus como nós
depois também há imprevistos que
acontecem em um dos imprevistos foi este
hora tem um aspecto simpático mas
chegamos numa aldeia onde fomos ver
então se estava com o avaí a colocação
das lâmpadas já tinham várias colocadas
nas casas está assim tá curva em temos
problemas com o macaco e foi que houve
uma taco agarrado e amarrado a a vida e
50 de uma capital é um animal selvagem
tenha que viver livro não é nas árvores
como como é seu costume não mas temos
que honrar até cavarmos porque nós
colocamos uma lâmpada vai atrás e teria
tampa
nós também aprendemos aqui aprendemos
que tivemos que melhorar um processo
porque a silagem que nós tínhamos
equacionado para aquelas garrafas para
não evaporar a água não estava a
funcionar não era é anti macaco então
tivemos que melhorar a sua agenda
a garrafa e depois de três anos e é que
o que é parte mais importante de todo
este processo porque é que depois nós
juntamos professores e principalmente os
alunos envolvidos neste projecto e
mostramos o resultado do seu trabalho e
é que nós começamos a assistir a a
mudança nos alunos é que nós começamos a
ver com os alunos estejam seguros e
passa a ser se dá porque nós estamos
também a formar as nossas escolas
estamos a formar cidadãos que no futuro
vão ter que tomar decisões prédios
importantes para a sua vida e nós
esperamos que eles tomem essas decisões
de forma consciente informa informá lá e
foi aqui neste momento os 11 a então era
isso e é isso que o meu professor de
matemática estava a tentar explicar a
qual nós andamos a fazer tal sparrow sam
custo dizer a todos o ar era isto como
pessoa difícil alguém tentava mostrar
quando eu aprender refração da luz
os alunos têm que entender o que esse
estudo e pra que estudam é que os
começam a dar sentido a sua aprendizagem
é que que deus começamos a ver que o
fato aprender vale a pena que é útil e
que vai ser útil para o seu futuro
também e é que nós pessoas também vemos
que falar temos a nossa tarefa cumprida
quando vemos que os alunos creche e
desenvolvem e passam a gostar e deixam
faltar às aulas e começam a ser pontuais
a mensagem que eu queria hoje deixar com
este meu testemunha que não é educação
see só que o transforma o mundo a
educação quando bem ministrava quando
saímos daquela metodologia expositivas
em tata que já se falou que hoje e
passamos para uma metodologia do
aprender fazendo é e a educação
transforma e muda pessoas e são as
pessoas passo a passo que gota d'água
vamos transformar nosso mundo obrigada
[Aplausos]